So I left California and moved to Florida.
After 14 transformational
years in Los Angeles
where we built careers, bought a house,
got married and had three kids,
my wife, Lindsey, and I decided
to pack up and relocate.
And we're not alone.
California's approach to the
pandemic made life here harder
than ever before.
I've reported extensively
on California's policies,
from the expensive and
unreliable energy grid
to the aggressive taxation and regulation,
from the draconian lockdowns
that permanently damaged all businesses
and kept children out of school
for longer than anywhere else
to the failure of city leaders to cope
with the nation's worst homelessness
and mental health crises.
Yeah, I've seen it all firsthand.
But my reasons for moving
aren't primarily political;
they're personal.
And California, I still love you.
Sometimes I really don't, but, yeah, I do.
14 years ago, my future
wife's Honda Accord hustled us
2,400 miles in three days
so that she could make it
for a job interview in Los Angeles.
We left behind friends,
family, and Florida,
trading the swamps of the Sunshine State
for the glamor of Hollywood.
We memorialized the moment
with blurry digital photos
snapped from the car window.
We soaked in the famous SoCal weather,
so consistently pleasant that
the outdoors anywhere else
just never quite lives up to it.
We gawked at the natural beauty
and gorged ourselves on the rich,
varigated culture of Los Angeles,
a city packed full of people
creative, daring, and delusional enough
to follow their dreams.
My kids are all California natives,
and life there on balance was good to me.
They trounce through mountain
streams in the Sierras,
hid inside centenarian redwoods,
splashed at the edge of
the vast cold Pacific,
played and learned alongside other kids
from around the world,
learned how to count
Mandarin, greet in Spanish,
and express their gratitude in Korean.
Then things started to change
both for us and in the world.
Beijing tries to show it's in control
of the epidemic consuming this country.
Coronavirus officially hitting the US.
Coronavirus now classified
as a public health emergency.
Coronavirus forcing millions
more Americans into virtual lockdown.
Over 75 million people
in New York, California,
Vermont, and Connecticut-
I've never seen so much open road on I10
as I did this Sunday
morning in March 2020.
Stay at home, 15 days
to flatten the curve.
As the dynamism of L.A. ground to a halt,
the smog cleared, the birds chirped,
and we would see and hear our surroundings
in a way we never had before.
It made us look at California differently.
The upsides and downsides each
coming into sharper focus.
The rolling blackouts are more unsettling
and the wildfire smoke more oppressive
when you're already stuck in your house
or compelled to wear a
mask once you step outside.
Gavin Newsom blames climate change,
but his policies matter too.
The forests weren't properly managed
and the increasingly solar
and wind-dependent grid is fragile.
Newsom personally hastened the closure
of California's last nuclear plant.
When Germany closed all of theirs,
emissions went up and so did prices.
My oldest son was still
in preschool last year
so he was spared much of the frustration
and social isolation of remote learning
that so many experienced.
But it was disturbing
to watch California
keep its schools closed
long after other countries
and states were demonstrating
that safe in-person
schooling was possible.
The governor's own kids attended
private school in-person
while most public school
campuses stayed empty.
The powerful teacher's
unions used their positions
to extract hundreds of
millions of additional dollars
during the shutdown.
And L.A.'s union issued a list of demands
that included a wealth
tax, Medicare for all,
and abandoned all new charter schools.
School's back now with
mandatory weekly testing,
social distancing, mandatory masking
for even the fully vaccinated,
and vaccine mandates
for all eligible kids.
And the situation on the streets,
already bad before COVID, only got worse
as L.A. Mayor Eric Garcetti's
underperforming $1.2 billion plan
to build homeless housing
completely stalled.
And the city faced a violent
crime and homicide spike.
I voted for and still
support sentencing reform.
I believe no person should
be jailed for drugs,
and think we need a social
safety net of some kind
for those who can't
take care of themselves.
But a city also needs the rule of law
and safe public spaces to function,
and many of California's
big cities are failing
on those fronts.
The city's cultural and
culinary life nearly died
as we shelter in place.
It's coming back in its own
socially distanced, masked,
and mandatory-vaccine-verified way.
But for many small businesses,
there will be no second life.
Shutting down outdoor
dining without any grounding
in science evidence or
logic is one judge ruling
against the forest closures put it,
"Ended the California dream
for many restaurateurs."
And yet California's political class seems
more secure than ever.
L.A.'s mayor has failed upward
towards a US ambassadorship.
The governor survived recall easily,
and the Democratic
supermajority is rushing
to make future recalls an impossibility.
And when one party rules,
those who've captured that
party can make the rules.
Teachers unions, firefighter
unions, prison guard unions,
state service employee unions.
Public sector unions feed public money
and power to themselves
so they can continually increase
that power and influence,
allowing them to feed more
money and power to themselves.
What about my power and your power
to make our own choices
about our own lives?
But as my moving date drew closer,
a new feeling washed over,
a blissful attachment
from California politics.
When your voice goes unheard,
it's sometimes better
to head for the exit.
But again, my move isn't purely political.
If it were, I might be in
New Hampshire right now,
surrounded by more of the like-minded.
Most of life isn't about
politics, thankfully.
See, people I love are in Florida,
and they're getting older as am I.
And it's a new world with new rules
where you can more easily live
and work from where you want.
And I still love you, California.
I made my career, my
home, and my family here.
I'll miss California.
Despite politics, this is still
a spectacularly beautiful,
diverse, and strange land
where the waves meet the mountains,
where people follow their dreams,
or lose their minds or both.
So I made it back to this
humid peninsula jutting
into the Gulf of Mexico.
It's familiar, but not
quite the same as before.
I'm sure I'll have more to
say about you soon, Florida.
With your terrifying reptiles,
and your COVID contrarianism,
and your lightning rod governor
who plays by different
rules for good and for ill.
The saying has been, "As goes
California, goes the nation."
Is that still true or is it Texas now?
Or is the importance of
geography simply diminished
in the network age?
Is Florida the future?
I don't really know, but it
is my future and my home.